when Jeopardy co-hosts Mayim Bialik and
Ken Jennings were tapped to take over
for the late Alex Trebek some long time
viewers were none too pleased in these
offensive comments from both co-hosts
didn't exactly win the many fans Mayim
Bialik has been a fixture on television
for as far back as many viewers can
remember back in the 90s she starred in
the titular role of Blossom Russo in the
NBC sitcom Blossom before pivoting to
Voice work on cartoons like Johnny Bravo
recess and Kim Possible today however
she's better known for her long-running
role as Amy Farrah Fowler on The Big
Bang Theory which she played beginning
in season 3 of the hit sitcom more
recently viewers will recognize her from
another sitcom call me cat and as one of
two recurring hosts on Jeopardy
following the passing of longtime host
Alex Trebek unfortunately despite her
background in science and academics
Bialik isn't always viewed as a popular
choice for the hosting gig on Jeopardy
this is because of controversial
comments that she made in a New York
Times op-ed that many viewed as victim
blaming as well as a host of other
problematic statements that she's made
regarding vaccines enter partnership
with the controversial neurological
supplement nereva in response to the
Harvey Weinstein Scandal Bialik wrote I
still make choices every day as a 41
year old actress that I think of as
self-protecting and wise I have decided
that my sexual self is best reserved for
private situations with those I am most
intimate with I dress modestly I don't
act flirtatiously with men as a policy
it is the last part of that statement
that Drew the most ire for Bialik as
many read it as shaming women or victim
blaming though she was clear throughout
that she sees herself as a feminist and
wishes that the world were different for
women and girls in the entertainment
industry the blowback was Swift from
opponents of her piece actor Gabrielle
Union tweeted that when she had been
sexually assaulted while working at a
Payless she had on a long tunic and
leggings she added so miss me with dress
modestly elsewhere Bialik served as the
public face for an Arriva a supplement
that psychology today called snake oil
this made some question her intentions
as many took it as Bialik using her
celebrity to cash in without properly
vetting the product that she was selling
on CBS between episodes of Jeopardy in
The Big Bang Theory this isn't all when
it comes to the criticism that Bialik
has received in terms of her takes on
medical matters despite being a
scientist herself the actor said
previously that she did not vaccinate
her children again she walked this back
somewhat by getting the flu shot in kova
19 vaccine later on but for many the
damage was already done this here I'm
gonna do something I literally haven't
done in 30 years
I'm gonna get a vaccine this had been
compounded by her promotion of
attachment parenting in her book beyond
the sling a real life guide to raising
confident loving children the attachment
parenting way this is because attachment
parenting or AP is a belief system that
is often seen as going hand in hand with
anti-vaccine beliefs while some fans
might point to fellow Jeopardy host Ken
Jennings as the easy alternative to
Bialik in the wake of these issues
Jennings also has a history of making
problematic statements in particular the
host and long time Jeopardy contestant
tweeted out an ableist post on Twitter
writing that there's quote nothing
sadder than a hot person in a wheelchair
Jennings has also been accused of sexism
and favoritism in an episode of Jeopardy
that aired on September 14 2022 Jennings
allowed a contestant to amend his answer
after he said constant instead of
constable a factor that many fans found
to be a double standard after he ruled
an answer incorrect from a previous
female contestant because she
mispronounced the answer despite being
correct
sadly this seems to show that neither of
Alex Trebek's Replacements may be the
right person for the job especially when
you consider the high bar that was set
by the host squeaky clean background and
generally beloved disposition as it
turns out some fans think both co-hosts
are well they're both losers